None of you have the balls to be with someone as beautiful as I am.
Okay.
My name is Sharelle holder and I'm a plus size model.
Take off your robe and look at your body in the mirror.
Describe the feelings and thoughts you have.
Well,
it's kind of a love hate relationship,
but I mean for now it's mostly love relationship.
My name is Chris.
I am a 22 years old.
I noticed that my cheeks,
I slow,
pretty chubby.
They're chubby or then
I would ideally like for them to be,
my name is Raquel Hargrove.
I think I feel very lucky that my body moves and it does the things I want it to
and yeah,
it feels good.
It feels,
it feels like a home.
I'm Mandy,
I'm 21 I feel very ambivalent,
like I look at myself and I don't hate anything.
I see.
Okay.
My name is Richard 19
so skewed.
I don't usually show off my body often.
Right.
This one,
this is,
this is new.
Definitely new.
Can I take it?
Go ahead.
Oh,
okay.
Do you feel pressure to have a specific shape?
See this is really interesting in my life right now as a plus size model because
I have been going through this process to really lose weight for my diabetes.
So in losing weight I'm no longer the ideal like size 14 but also the modeling
realm is shifting too.
They want more pear shaped and I'm more hourglass.
So yeah,
I definitely feel pressured right now.
I think it very much was like to do with my relationship with men.
I've never been like outright insulted for my height at all,
but everyone is like,
oh,
I loved your tall.
It's so cool.
Like some guys are gonna love that.
Not me though.
I don't know.
I can,
I just,
I can do personally I'm like,
you're not original.
None of you have the balls to be with someone as beautiful as I am.
That's the problem.
That's it.
That's all it is.
I'm six two and if I had a wish it would be to go back in time and spend less
time caring about what my body looks like.
I just hated being so much taller than everyone.
I think there's women were made to feel like we're supposed to be and I am very
grateful now for this height that I have,
that I walk into a room and I'm like,
you have to listen.
Okay.
You can't ignore me.
I'm here to take up space and I'm not going to feel bad about it.
Okay.
What type of body are you attracted to?
I guess the more PC answer wouldn't be,
it's all about the personality.
No.
Uh,
ideal body.
I guess I would prefer someone who I guess is either like fit or like curvy,
but it's not necessarily a deal breaker if they're not those things.
Yeah.
This is a hard question for me because I'm slightly on the asexual spectrum
label that's helpful for me is demisexual,
which means that like I literally cannot feel any physical attraction unless
there is some pretense of like emotional connection.
I feel like I am relatively privileged to be in a body that's not skewed away
from beauty standards and social norms.
Like I have like a small figure.
I haven't gotten a lot of like,
or at least I haven't listened to a lot of messages that have told me that I
should change.
So I look at myself and I'm like,
Yup,
that's me.
Okay.
Hi.
How do you love your body?
I don't know.
I really try to sleep a lot.
I think that's like a thing for me where I recognized that I kind of start to
fall apart if I'm like not sleeping.
It was like I don't care enough about like this shell that I'm living in enough
to like take care of it and try to eat healthy and try to like drink water and
try to sleep.
I would probably start primarily with food,
especially when I'm taking care of my voice.
I do a lot of singing,
so I never drank like a full can of soda before.
So
yeah.
Exercise,
play,
really.
I am.
I'm not,
I'm not that occurs,
but it's,
it's dietary habits,
right?
This voice matters to me a lot.
Well,
the rest of this body is the most significant thing per se.
My voice stands out.
I'm able to just be myself while singing.
Of course I have my insecurities,
but you know,
it's,
that's my life.
You saying just a little bit for a sweatshirt
before the pool
passes my,
I'm going to go and taste back into my life.
Yeah.
What is your favorite activity to do that involves your body?
For me,
my favorite activity to do on this,
the body is dancing.
I love dancing and that's kind of like,
I don't know,
almost like for me like whether it's twerking or salsa or whatever it is,
like I just need to let it go.
It makes me feel sexy I guess.
Yeah.
I guess for me it's weight training.
Uh,
it was initially I guess a mindset I had where if you were like more muscular,
like a skinny,
whatever it may be,
that it would magically make everything great.
Yeah.
If I had like more,
you know,
brought her shoulders or like a six pack and like,
like girls wouldn't be running,
running.
It's gone to me a little bit better and a lot of regards in terms of like just
how I see myself,
how like my confidence levels and like how I go about my life,
but at the same time it's hilarious processing growing up,
just being more defined by the fact that I was overweight,
I kind of envied in a way people that were in better shape.
From my perspective,
it seemed like they had everything all together.
I guess kind of being on the flip side of that coin now it's very different in
terms of you don't have everything set,
you don't have everything together just because you're of a better shape.
My body,
my shape is a reflection of the fact that I don't let shape define me as much.
Anymore.
A struggle that you've experienced in life that involves your body?
I think it just has to do with the Eczema again.
Yeah,
it was really bad.
As a kid I would always wear long clothes so I could hide my arms.
Like I became like really quiet,
really close and like the way I dressed kind of reflected that.
I went through the same exact thing,
but definitely that wearing long sleeves,
long pants,
even when it's the dead of summer growing up and not only having bad eczema but
also be the Chubby kid was like really rough cause it's like,
okay,
nobody likes me,
you know,
like no boys like me kind of thing.
And I was always taller than them too.
So it's like,
okay,
well we've made it,
we're here.
It's like super cool to hear because you've seen so like in your body.
Yeah.
And I think I had to go through those struggles to become this person,
you know,
that it really made me mature really fast.
Do you think your body is beautiful?
I do.
Um,
it's kind of like a roller coaster ride up and down in terms of I'm happy with
it and then I'm not happy with it.
I like my curves.
I um,
just like the way that it's shaped,
I think it's very flattering.
Um,
I like the way clothes look on my body.
So though not perfect.
Um,
I think that she gets the job done.
Let's see.
Has anyone ever criticized your body?
My family.
Like it's really easy for relative to say like,
oh,
like you should eat more.
Literally every time I Skype with my parents,
they all know your face look smaller.
I'm like,
Oh,
like what?
Like my aunt kept annoying me.
Eat more burgers.
[inaudible] yes.
And I'm like,
I'm eating,
I'm eating at the end it like,
it's like I never gained a pound.
And sometimes I'm like,
how did I lose a pound?
At this point,
I've sorta just numbed it out.
I'm like,
all right.
That's just who I am.
I'm just,
I'm okay with it.
It's not the most outrageous body.
It's not the most,
you know,
I have a six pack or I need sing the song.
It's sort of just,
it's me
and I am beautiful.
I am the best person who I can be right now.
And while there's always room for improvement,
there's always the state where you can just relax,
be you,
and be the most beautiful person you can be at that moment.
Huh?